milkshakers hello it's me rain wilson
love love
love
love
love
love um we're never gonna be able to
clear that song okay that you just cost
us like and fifty thousand dollars sorry
i'm i'm i'm brimming with love rain i
just got back
from a weekend couples retreat with my
wife i learned
how to build our relationship how to be
closer to each other i'm just i'm
bubbling over with love and affection um
you're kind of grossing me out because
when you bubble over with love your your
your sinewy torso rise
in a in a way that kind of made me throw
up in my mouth that's just my love
language yo but don't touch your nipples
right now okay please
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cass media and soul
pancake
[Music]
what do you know what are you talking
about you went on
you have a great marriage you're just
wonderful we i have the greatest
marriage i have the greatest wife
and uh you know we just decided hey
let's make this even better let's let's
go from a to a plus relationship so we
traveled all the way to the orcas island
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere in
washington state
and we went to the home of john and
julie gottman you know the gottmans have
you ever heard of the gottmans reign i
have heard of the gottmans yes they're
infamous marriage counselors and
psychologists and authors they're like
in their 80s i mean they literally wrote
the book actually they wrote 40 books
on relationships how to build
relationships and you know we just went
there for like a little refresher and we
came back i feel like i've got like a
master's degree in love right now
oh so what did you uh what did you learn
well
i learned mostly how to deal with
conflict right
how to deal with comfort which actually
i gotta be honest like i i i think it's
gonna help us in our relationship
okay um
we don't we don't have any issues i
don't think i think we get along pretty
well i think we work together great as a
team
what what are you saying that we can
improve i i think our connection our
sense of connection could be a little
bit stronger i think our okay you know
okay fine what how do we connect deeper
well first of all i notice that you're
getting a little defensive okay a little
bit i'm a little defensive uh i don't
there's no need for defensiveness uh and
you certainly don't need to stonewall
uh and you know this is i'm not giving
you any criticism
here i'm certainly not showing you
any contempt those are the four horsemen
of the apocalypse according to john
gottman the death of relationships
uh
okay you know i just i i'm just here i'm
just here
to help you be the best version of
yourself rain that's that's what i have
learned
well then sometimes just shut the [ __ ]
up
and let me ask some [ __ ]
questions to the guests okay
so what i hear you saying is that you no
one needs to shut the [ __ ] up
okay i hear that i accept that you are
rapidly building contempt right now
this is really not working you know what
this is not working we need to bring on
our guests because
uh we have an incredible guest who is
going to dig deep in and really truly
help us all
connect better
uh
find uh solutions for loneliness have
deeper friendships
eric barker is here
to help us get to the bottom
of all of this so eric barker blogged
for years about human behavior and
self-improvement science he's got over
half a million subscribers to his weekly
newsletter uh he's a former hollywood
screenwriter he's worked on projects for
walt disney and fox and
other studios he wrote a wall street
journal bestseller called barking up his
barker barking up the wrong tree sold
over half a million copies been
translated into 19 languages
and this book
uh plays well with others is um getting
to the core
of human relationships
which you know i feel like i'm already
at the core
rain i don't i don't really if it's cool
with you i think i'll just uh i'll sit
this podcast out because i feel like i
know set it up i need this one you
obviously don't i think you should just
sing and write your little torso
over in glendale or wherever the hell
you live you talk to eric barker i will
play with my nipples eric
it's great to be here you look like
you're in a in a padded room somewhere
did they let you out of the straight
jacket for this interview
uh it's it's just it's a weekend pass
this is what happens when you write
about relationships
you know eventually you start to lose it
and then they just like throw you into a
padded tail that's it that's it i will
tell you though that it is not the
weekend so
uh what happened
i filed for the extension but we'll see
what we'll see what comes back
um listen we absolutely love this book
plays well with others eric barker um
i'm
you know i i'm i'm not all the way
through it it is uh it's fascinating and
funny
it is chock-a-block
with examples and science you did so
much work on this book and the reason i
say i'm not finished with it yet is at
the end you promise the meaning of life
so we're going to get to that later
we're going to get to that at the end a
little bit more on the meaning of life
but whatever it's fine we'll keep going
but
uh nonetheless um i'm just going to ask
a boring old softball question but what
prompted
this book i mean there's so many
incredible ideas you delve into
you know you you get into these tropes
and sayings and truisms about human
interaction and psychology like can you
judge a book by its cover
is a friend in need truly a friend
indeed does love conquer all is no man
an island and then you really
dig deep in um in so many ways
into those primal questions but what
prompted this this journey it's an
incredible journey that you've
undertaken
well thank you i i mean i i took the
structure of it my first book was about
success and i took the maxims of success
do nice guys finish last is it what you
know or who you know you know and just
kind of stress tested those i was a big
fan of mythbusters so i i kind of
stressed out that those looked at the
social science and said is this true
and you know for follow-up i like freud
basically said that the two key elements
were kind of like you know work and love
were the two key elements of life and i
handled like work and success so i
figured i'd look at relationships and
frankly i'd never been like really great
with relationships so i thought it'd be
good and then what was crazy was
literally two weeks after i closed the
deal for the book uh california locked
down for the pandemic and i realized oh
like people are gonna i'm not the only
one who's gonna need this book people
are gonna need this book so it kind of i
became a man on a mission yeah
absolutely i mean we are definitely in
that place where we all could use a
little bit of guidance
about you know how to just even be in
public let alone go back to uh having
meaningful uh relationships again but
one of the things that's really cool
about this is that a lot of it is about
the science behind you know
relationships like this isn't just you
kind of you know spouting off it's not
it's not like just a a self-help or
advice you know how to get laid by eric
barker
we'll talk offline we'll talk offline
about that
but uh but tell us a little bit about
kind of uh how you dug into all the
science and the research and the data
that that you provide in this
book
i mean i i've been looking at you know
like social science research on my blog
for like 13 years now so
that's been a help but i had to i had to
really wait wait wait wait wait a blo a
blog
what is this is this 2007
you've probably heard of the stone age
and the iron age and there's the blog
age is this really narrow area pre
tick-tock
is your blog on geocities
uh no no
no it's uh it's it's only on aol
aol not tumblr okay okay anyway sorry
i so i but i had i had to dig a lot
deeper and like so much of this was the
reading and and it was crazy how
lopsided it was because like for love
and marriage the
the problem was there's so much there's
just so
much and then i'm like whoa finally wow
i did all the like love and marriage
reading and then i go to look at
friendship and it's the complete reverse
like there's no institution for
friendship there's no friendship
therapists so there's not a lot of
research on friendship and so i really i
really had to to dig i mean i i even
went back to start looking at aristotle
and philosophy to try and to try and get
some answers but i i did end up finding
research but it was tricky
and we weren't quite sure when we
started this what is the life's big
question that we wanted to dig into with
you we talked about loneliness but we've
done another episode on loneliness we
wanted to talk about friendships but we
just did an episode on friendships with
jenna fisher and angela kinsey from the
office but it seems like that the heart
of your book is just about
human
connection
and you launch with this uh wonderful
story about learning hostage negotiation
techniques
and then how that transfers
to
to marriage and human interaction can
you tell us a little bit about that
yeah it's funny because so much of the
the
literature in terms of like marriage and
family therapy and stuff always
emphasizes active listening and i went i
trained with the nypd hostage
negotiation team and they use active
listening
and i was like can you explain active
listening to the to to our active
listeners to our not so active listeners
basically basically it's you know it's
listening to what the person says you
know acknowledging it you know repeating
back to them you know what you what you
heard from them basically instead of
telling somebody i hear you you're
demonstrating you know i i heard you you
are making it clear demonstrably that
you're listening you're paying attention
you're you're you're you're you're
mirroring back to them their thoughts
paraphrasing them so that they really
feel understood and that this starts to
escalate towards the level of rapport
and
what's really funny about it was i went
hostage negotiation team i it's i see
this you know in practice it's really
awesome and then afterwards the
negotiators are like oh by the way you
know this this isn't going to work at
home with your spouse and i was like
what
and then i dug into the research and
sure enough you know active listening is
great when you're a third party when
you're a hostage negotiator or a
therapist when you're removed from it
but when you're the subject of the fight
when you're in the middle of the
argument you know again like active
listening would be a good idea but most
people can't do it when accusations are
getting thrown at them so it sounds
great and it would be great but most
people practically speaking can't do it
is there is there something that you
learned in that process that actually
did help yeah i mean what was what was
really critical this is research by john
gottman
is there were he has done an insane
amount of research on love and marriage
and he found you know four critical
things in conversations that
you know are highly correlated with
divorce like over the 85 percent level
the four the four horsemen of the
apocalypse
four horsemen of the relationship
apocalypse yeah
and those were criticism defensiveness
stonewalling and contempt
and basically you as everybody says you
do need to communicate and complaining
is okay most people are afraid if they
complain the relationship's gonna
dissolve but complaining that you have
to do it to raise issues that's fine
most marriages don't end because of
screaming matches they end because
people stop communicating and they live
parallel lives
so
complaining is good criticism is when
you make the complaint personal when you
attack the other person's character
criticism's bad defensiveness is when
somebody makes an accusation and you
respond with an accusation and the
conflict just escalates
you know then defensively that's
defensiveness stonewalling is when you
just shut down when somebody raises
something and you just don't respond and
that's taken as dismissiveness and
contempt is when you see your partner on
a lower level than you and contempt is
the worst contempt gottman called it
sulfuric acid for love
you know i mentioned this uh at the top
of the show but i just got back from a
weekend at john gottman's house
wow uh my wife and i uh went there and
one of the things that's really funny
about him because if you're you know
those who are unfamiliar with with the
gottmans john and julie gottmans they're
like the you know the godfathers of
relationship he's written like 40 books
or whatever
you know they're really they're really
sort of the
the first couple
uh of of relationships but it but it
should be noted it should be noted that
their stuff is based really on science
it's all research exactly studying so
many couples and documenting their
arguments and you know couples that come
in ones that get divorced versus ones
that don't is really able to accurately
predict um what couples are going to end
up together and
and separate um i'm just trying to
underline that there's a whole kind of
library of research under the stuff that
he's done gottman actually
he previously was actually a
mathematician i mean like far from being
fluffy he came from the most rigorous of
rigor in terms of disciplines and then
use that that incredible knowledge of
like math statistics and everything and
turn it towards relationships
no one knows what you're looking for in
a doctor better than you and no one's
better at giving you the tools to find
the perfect doctor than zoc doc the
people who created zocdoc found the
major pain points in health care it's
all the things that weren't working and
said enough and they made booking a
great doctor surprisingly pain free
sockdoc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed they
take your insurance and are available
when you need them you can read up on
local doctors get verified patient
reviews and see what other real humans
had to say about their visit so when you
walk into that doctor's office you're
set up to see someone in your network
who gets you this is how i found my
doctor rain i've seen her like four or
five times i love her she's now my
primary care physician thank you zocdoc
so find the doctor that is right for you
book an appointment that works for your
schedule every month millions of people
use zocdoc
and we are some of those millions it's
our go-to whenever we need to find and
book a doctor so in the chaotic world of
healthcare let zocdoc be your trusted
guide to find a quality doctor it's pain
free go to zocdoc dot com slash
milkshake and download the zockdoc app
for free then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours
that's z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash
milkshake z-o-c
d-o-c zocdoc dot com slash milkshake
one of the things reza and i are really
fascinated about and we have some
follow-up questions about social media
and what not coming is
this contemporary disconnection that i
think we all feel that social scientists
and psychologists write about
um
e.m forster says only connect
um we're in this mental health epidemic
with young people that
um is absolutely
devastating can you tell us a little bit
about what you learned about the kind of
the history of disconnection and
loneliness
uh in the modern world
yeah this is this is a lot but i spent i
spent a lot of time looking at the
history it was fascinating uh basically
you know uh fail birdie is a historian
at the university of york and she said
basically before the 19th century
loneliness didn't exist
that's an exaggeration but not by much
you know basically before the 19th
century we were all embedded in
communities religions tribes groups
nations there were really these strong
aspects of community and we always felt
a level of connection because for the
most part historically for the vast
majority of human existence you couldn't
survive without other people so you were
always embedded in a group now for the
first time you can live pretty separated
from others and as humans we tend to
take the easy way and
it's now harder like we have to make a
proactive effort to connect with others
and that's where the trickiness is
coming from but so 19th century we saw
that shift you know and then in the 20th
century uh there was a book by robert
putnam a professor at harvard called
bowling alone and he talked about how in
the second half of the 20th century we
saw you know people used to think about
like the elk lodge and bowling leagues
and
and that doesn't that almost seems
archaic now and he tracked what happened
and he tracked a lot of in the 20th
century second half of the 20th century
to television basically that we were
experiencing parasocial relationships we
were getting a lot of our
our community from tv which is you know
kind of one way
and
then in 2008 when the writer's strike
happened there was a research study
there and they found that for a lot of
people when shows went off the air it
was like a breakup that was the
emotional equivalent for people because
they had developed these these their
kinships with television characters now
the 21st century we have social media
which again you see some studies say
positive some studies say negative but
the issue is that we only have so many
hours in a day for the social budget and
if it's all going to instagram it's not
going to face to face and there are real
negatives in that because we don't get
the same things from online connection
that we do from face to face
one of the things i'm doing
this summer as we're recording these
episodes is i i'm literally
eric i have the greatest
job you probably know eric weiner and
the geography of bliss his book which is
very much in line with the kind of stuff
that you do so we we built a tv show
around that concept i'm traveling around
the world
looking for happiness okay and
what can we learn from other cultures
and communities that have maybe
something a little bit more figured out
about happiness that we don't have here
and what can i rain personally learn
along the way so far we've gone to
iceland and bulgaria and ghana off to
thailand and japan next and um
it's a fascinating journey um but
let's get a little more specific
you know there's this american narrative
that did start in the 18th and 19th
centuries which is you know
don't tread on me
right kind of
rugged individualism
um
so how much of our particular american
disconnect
is a byproduct of some kind of
national mythology or national identity
that's a good question i i didn't delve
too much into the specific politics
angle but what was interesting you know
to your point is that issue of
individualism and that's one of the
things failed already talked about is
that word didn't really get used in the
same way until the 19th century and
america certainly has an emphasis on
individualism and what's what's critical
the a lot of the misunderstanding a lot
of us make when it comes to loneliness
is that we think it's about spending
time with other people but john cacciobo
who's the leading researcher on
loneliness he did a study and found that
lonely people don't spend any less time
with others than non-lonely people do
which sounds crazy but
we all we have all felt lonely in a
crowd you know and and we've all gone on
trips and not felt horribly lonely the
issue is loneliness is how you feel
about your relationships and so that
issue of individualism
of feeling and that's what loneliness is
because when you're you when you
perceive
hey i have connections i feel other
people care about me then you have
what's called solitude which is a
positive vivec murthy has said solitude
is a positive loneliness meanwhile is
correlated with every negative health
metric you can imagine but the
distinction between the two isn't
necessarily the proximity of other
people it's how you feel about the
connection but that issue of
individualism when we feel you know more
apart more distant more separate that's
harmful when we don't see ourselves as
part of a group
and
brett ford university berkeley has done
research on this and to your point about
looking around the world in terms of
happiness she said one thing about
america is
we think of happiness from an
individualistic perspective so we always
think what do i have to do what do i
have to get how much money do i have to
make meanwhile especially in eastern
cultures the perception of happiness is
communal is as a group
and so that is very effective in america
we have the perspective of
individualistic happiness and that takes
a strong direction it actually really
doesn't work in general if we're going
to pursue happiness we need to do it
from that group perspective not the
individualistic one yeah it's really
fascinating that you you talk about that
you know the difference between this
sort of individualistic
um
society that we live in in communal
societies not just in asia but in the
middle east latin america africa [ __ ]
everywhere everywhere else basically um
and i like i like what you're saying
here this idea that loneliness isn't
about the amount of time you spend with
people but about the the quality of your
connections with those around you at the
same time of course
we are more alone and individualistic
than we've ever been um there's a survey
here that that says that in 1921
of the u.s population
lived alone and today one in seven
americans so one quarter of all u.s
households are just one person
and
the pandemic as we were kind of you know
joking about earlier has obviously made
that so much worse right it we've we've
read so much and certainly rayne and i
have talked so much about the the health
consequences of loneliness the pandemic
has has created a real sort of mental
health emergency
um in the united states what did you
discover when it comes to those kinds of
both physical health and mental health
uh
consequences of a lack of connection
i mean what was most fascinating to me
was the neuroscience studies that
when people feel lonely their brains
scan for threats twice as fast
which you know from from a historical
context in our ancestral environment you
know makes sense if you don't think help
is coming you better be on the lookout
for danger but obviously that's not very
conducive to happiness you know to
constantly be looking for the negative
that's probably the opposite of most
happiness advice that's incredible the
neuroscience of like when you are lonely
your you're you're scanning for threats
twice as much and that my mind reels
like because you don't have community
you don't have people around you
watching your back
um and then
what happens
when you're lonely and you're scanning
for threats is anxiety and this
because
anxiety is kind of the touchstone of
kind of young america these days
everyone has an anxiety disorder uh i
have an anxiety disorder but and it must
come from that essential
you know looking for threats that aren't
really there so this feeling of
impending doom
um
that is incessant
um
but i i just think that's uh that's
absolutely incredible so it that just
reveals so much to me i hadn't heard
that statistic before
no it's it's fascinating because the
i was blown away because the other thing
is it's like that's it's not even
conscious you know it's like this is the
work they do in an fmri where people
aren't even really aware of it it's just
boom their brain is able to you know
detect and see the negative twice as
quickly it's operating beneath the
surface you wouldn't even be conscious
of it you're just gonna have like you
said that ever-present kind of hum of
anxiety and
we
you know we try to alleviate this again
we go to the quick and easy way which
you know can often be you know tv or
social media but it was fascinating to
me to see that when they did a study of
uh cancer support groups when they
surveyed people who did them online
almost everyone in the group was dealing
with depression most likely the clinical
level and when they surveyed people who
were in face-to-face groups almost none
of them are you know there's something
in that face-to-face
in being with a community and really
feeling like we're there as opposed to
having that that artificial gap you know
between us it's it's really that issue
of i talk a lot about friendship but
there's also to your point the issue of
community and one study that blew me
away this was just from 2020
was that if you have five friends you
know you're gonna feel supported you're
gonna feel you know cared for
but the difference is if those five
friends know each other you're going to
feel even more support you're going to
feel even happier same amount of friends
on average same amount of support but
when those friends know each other now
it shifts from one-on-one friendships to
more of a community your friends can say
hey you know rain's feeling down we
should throw a party for him we should
take him out they can coordinate they
can do things those are the abilities
that a community has that one one-on-one
friendships don't and we've lost a lot
of that and there there's so much there
that we we often don't think about you
tell a lot of stories
in the book about other people
uh let's talk about your your stories
here tell us about your your
relationship
history the good the bad the ugly and
and what like writing this book
kind of taught you and
when it comes to actually
having the kind of healthy
uh connections uh that you you write
about uh that are so important in the
book i mean you know
again i was never really good with
relationships basically uh when
psychologists study personality they
look at the big five personality traits
one of which is agreeableness and uh out
of a possible 100 i scored a four
so um
wow
yeah
hey you know good
really impressive stuff but like
it's kind of comical because like
you know what makes it difficult where
i'm always kind of challenging things
questioning things and so some of the
things that i think have you know helped
me do well in terms of my writing and
this mythbusters you know maxim crushing
approach to to uh science there's some
of the same things that have you know
caused me problems in my relationships
is that i'm not very easygoing i'm i'm
kind of you know quick to question and
challenge and be skeptical and
i i could probably calm down a little
bit in terms of that but you know what i
learned in terms i'm already applying
things in terms of like with my
friendships you know knowing that time
and vulnerability are critical and those
are two things i never really focused on
i never like made a lot of time for it
and i certainly wasn't good at opening
up and in the process of like delving
into some of this science and and some
of this research do you think that
that's made you
uh
better at forming and maintaining
relationships
i mean it
the the crazy thing was that like
eric okay yeah i've already uh skeptical
about your answer like
all right i'm sorry go ahead no i was
just gonna say it was like it was very
funny to be reading all this
relationship research when i was locked
down for the pandemic so i'm like
sitting here reading about here's how
not having good relationships will kill
you and meanwhile i can't leave the
house uh so it was like the best time to
learn because i didn't have anything
else to do but it was the worst time to
practice
so i haven't been able to full-on apply
these things because between the
research the book but i'm i'm looking
forward to and the small steps i have
taken have have shown results
one thing we talk a lot about on the
show is social media and how it connects
to loneliness how it connects to
anxiety and you know our
current kind of
modern
state of being
and you mentioned it briefly before
parasocial relationships this idea that
you have a relationship you had
mentioned a tv show um
but but now on social media you have
relationships with the people you follow
and you like and you friend and
sometimes they friend you and sometimes
they don't but it's it's a false kind of
friendship now we've dug into the evils
of social media a lot on this show but
you also have some surprising things to
say about what we can learn from social
media and the benefits of it and and
what and what they might bring can you
talk a little bit about that
yeah i mean if you do have healthy
relationships and some of your friends
live far away you know then hey great
that allows you to stay in touch you
know that's fine it's like if you don't
live nearby somebody zoom calls can can
be great you know the the real issue
that's clear you know because there are
some positives respects real issues that
clear is when social media cannibalizes
face-to-face time it's a problem you
know when when we use it to amplify you
know our relationships if you're using
you know if you're using instagram to
message with somebody and set up a time
to get together for coffee hey that's
fantastic if you use instagram to see
that your friends had a new baby and
then you call them or go see them now
again you know it's an unalloyed
positive you know it is helping you to
connect with them be you know be aware
of what's going on with them the issue
is we just don't want it to completely
take over the limited amount of social
time that we have you know we don't want
it to become a replacement i i i in the
book i allergize it to dessert where
it's like you know dessert's great
dessert's tasty but if you eat chocolate
cake for every meal
then it's replacing real food and that's
a bad idea
what do you think we're headed as a
society now with this current trend that
we're talking about
toward
even greater and greater disconnection
whether it's because of you know the
pandemic or social media or just you
know rampant americanism or you know all
the other issues that are that are
involved here but
i i think we all agree that we are
becoming
increasingly more disconnected what what
do you think
is the future as that continues
to me i think ironically
the the issue is a lot of the
institutions and connections that we had
in the past broke down
sometimes that's good sometimes those
weren't so great you know and some of
them have strengthened you know which in
some ways is a positive in other ways we
often you know talk about the issue of
tribalism you know the issue is we need
to find more ways to connect we can't
exclusively rely on a handful because
then we get into you know in group out
group is one of the most fundamental
principles in psychology is that when
you're part of a group those out you
treat those outside of it different
those inside of it different
but the issue is if we only have one
group then the people inside it are good
and people outside it can be perceived
as very bad but we don't have to have
only have one group you know you have
one group you might have one group in
the workplace you had one group at home
you might have one group in your
neighborhood you might have one group of
old friends
we can expand the number of groups that
we are a part of and find you know other
ways to connect if that's religion or
politics if that's national or on the
other hand if it's interest sports
hobbies you know we can find more ways
to connect we just can't retreat into
these like one group and and you know
kind of
you know turn the others into enemies we
need to have multiple groups overlapping
so that we have more ways to connect
with one another and we don't we don't
get caught in these kind of us versus
them views
you mentioned uh this study by is it
george vellante i'm not sure how to
pronounce his name
um
valencia
yes yes
okay um
i i i've read a little bit about the
study it's it's taken place over like
like
five or six decades yeah yeah and he
boils down
uh his study
to to one thing about uh you know kind
of life boils down to simply
our relationships to other people
um
so in your book
you promise the meaning of life now i
know a lot of the listeners haven't read
your book and we really want you to buy
the book everybody read the whole thing
it's fascinating
if you love
uh stories and psychology and insights
you're gonna absolutely dig it
but you do get
to
what you found the meaning of life to be
after you dug into
so many of these kind of essential
fundamental psychological concepts do
can we get a sneak peek do we do can we
have a little nibblet right now the
meaning of life come on just a teeny
little taste little taste just just a
little soup song a little aperitif
[Laughter]
and i really would
encourage you to
take the time right now and like distill
you had all of these experiments you
read all these books you read all these
parables and like you say maxims about
friendships and connection and
loneliness that you dug into
walk us down that that path those that
trail of these breadcrumbs and how you
got to this
ultimate
uh really beautiful kind of synopsis of
the meaning of life
i mean
for me it was like there's so many
facets of the kind of the relationship
diamond you know and i and i don't have
uh you know a hotline of metaphysical
truth so i was you know i was kind of
concerned like what this but it came
down to
you know two specific studies by uh a
great researcher roy baumeister at fsu
and what he found was the issue of what
what what quality promotes a feeling of
meaning in life in other words when when
x happens to us or we feel x
when do we most feel that life has
meaning and that there's meaning for us
and that it would be causal not just
correlated causal and what he found was
a feeling of belonging when we feel we
belong when we feel a part of a group
that we are connected that others will
sacrifice for us that we will sacrifice
for them that when we have a feeling of
belonging that's when we most feel that
there is meaning in life so in the end
you know meaning in life it's like comes
down to belonging we are a social
species and to the degree that you can
increase the feeling that you belong you
know in a group with others and you're
connected
you're you're the amount of meaning in
life that you feel will increase i think
that's right that sounds right to me
doesn't it sound right to you rain it
absolutely does and
but here's the problem
and this may may not be
the time to dig into this in this
particular
episode but
it it feels tribal it feels communal
like when we lived in caves and we lived
in valleys and we lived in little human
nests
we felt like we belonged we had a shared
mythology
and um
and family and ancestors and stories and
the connection to the nature around us
and that's all well and good but what we
see happening in the united states so
much is that
we have so many warring tribes so many
different tribes
that other
the other tribes
um creating so much
discord so
how do we translate that does that mean
like find your tribe is it is it really
that simple or or do we have to think
about
community building and finding tribal
belonging and meaning in a different
context a much larger more unified
context because i don't think that that
study means like go find your bowling
league with people that look like you
and feel your belonging at your church
and you all have the same skin color
because that's not how the world is
working these days and i think that so
much again so much of this of the
disillusion of of
um
kind of
of unity you know comes from so much of
our country trying to fiercely defend
that their tribes that
worked 50 or 100 years ago and no longer
kind of work in the modern day
i don't know no i i i hear you i think
the the issue here is what
to your point what you said about
community building where every community
the theme that runs through the book for
all relationships from friendship to
marriage to communities is a story
you know it's like when when we feel
someone's a friend
our self-identity and our vision of them
start to blur the venn diagram overlaps
when when i ask you
does do you have this quality or does
your best friend have this quality you
will answer slower than if i asked you
about an acquaintance because you have
to disentangle yourself
from the person you're close to in your
mind that's empathy that is closeness
when in marriage gottman the way that he
divines he's able to detect within you
know what whether a couple will divorce
in five years with over 90 accuracy how
he does that is by asking the couple to
tell their story and every community has
a story an origin story what binds them
together
what we need is more stories instead of
having one story one tribe one group you
know you can get that community from you
know you know politics or religion
you can also feel that level of
community at comic con
you know it's like we we need to have
more groups we need to not make it
mutually exclusive one group one tribe
that's the problem when groups just
become mutually exclusive as opposed to
having being a part of and feeling
belonging from a number of groups where
we we might not share the same religion
we might not you know be citizens of the
same country but hey we might both be
star wars fans you can bond with someone
over that and feel a kinship we we need
more stories we need more ways to
connect with others not one singular one
which excludes all else and screams burn
the heretic
so
not just connections
but many connections more connections
interconnections
uh i think that makes sense uh eric will
you join our group
uh the the reza rayne metaphysical
milkshake group yeah
absolutely same time tomorrow
it actually is the same time tomorrow
we've got two
we've got two to record tomorrow we
would like it
we would however like it if you just
keep your mouth shut though you can
we'd like you on the zoom with us
so we feel like you've got our back and
you're supporting us in the making of
this podcast but we don't want you to
actually participate is that okay
just cool just just raise eyebrows and
and like occasionally like shake my head
exactly rain rain likes his uh podcast
guests like he likes his friends quiet
yep yep
i talk enough for for several people so
uh eric barker this has been such a
fascinating conversation the book is
called plays well with others so many
really fun stories in here some great
lessons about
how to create uh relationships um and
how to sustain relationships and of
course the meaning of life which you get
literally on the second to last
page of the book you forced me to read
270
pages before
you got to the end there but it's okay
uh i i forgive you for that uh thank you
so much for being on the milkshake pod
it was great to be here guys thank you
very much thanks eric it was great great
conversation thank you
wow that was really
profound and especially towards the end
there that really got me thinking about
uh loneliness and its connection to
anxiety
and uh
the idea that um
we have to build a new idea of what a
tribe is we can't just go back to
an old way of being in a tribe who are
your who are your tribes
reza what try what tribes are you a part
of what are your communities honestly
like nowadays and we you know
milkshakers know we've mentioned this
before it's kind of just my family
nowadays that's not enough dude that's
not gonna cut it that's what people say
that's what people say
i need i need a bigger tribe people i
need well listen i went to your birthday
party uh a month or two ago and it was
so nice meeting all of your your friends
i mean a lot of them were
parents at your kid's school which
happens to all of us when we have kids
in elementary school all of a sudden
like
our friends our connections are the
folks that we meet in the in the parking
lot and at the events and at the
assemblies and whatnot
um
but uh so many great writer friends um
that was really cool um
i guess my tribes are
well
you know in my faith community in the
baha'i faith that's kind of a
a nice tribe i'm in 12-step recovery
which is
a nice yeah that's a pretty weird deep
meaningful tribe and
deep tribe i got a fantasy football
league
right
that's a nice little tribe i met i
joined this tennis club up the street so
i have my little um
very very white tennis friends
and um
and the office family we still kind of
text and
stay in touch with each other that's you
know maybe what we need to do here is we
got to take eric's advice
and
like connect our tribes you know what
i'm saying we need to connect i'll
connect into one of your tribes you
connect into one of mine like let's see
never really can your family join my
fantasy football league
uh
well you can join my family
and then i'll join your football league
will you cook um persian food i mean
every sunday my my man every sunday
every sunday is kebab night at the aslan
household k-bob
any any fess in june
gourmet
you come over we'll adopt you as like
uncle rain and then i'll make you some
fess in june that's our connection and
then i'll join your fantasy uh football
tribe because honestly like i'm not very
good at tennis
i never really watch an episode of the
office is that a show on tv or something
i don't is that a thing anyway yeah um
and uh you know the rest of your your
tribes just yeah not not as appealing
but i will join your fantasy football
league and then okay
we're full up right now but i'm sure
we're going to lose a player we got 14
we got 14 players and you are first on
the wait list
wow wait listed into your tribe
yeah all right then um uh so i'll let
you know i'll get back to you babe but
um truly thank you to eric barker what a
wonderful conversation um and
folks we are going to be giving away
some copies of eric's new book plays
well with others the first five people
okay listen up first five people that
write a review
for metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts and email a screenshot of that
review
to metaphysical at cast media.com that's
what the k cast media.com
will be sent a copy of the book
so get on it free book write a review
a glowing review it doesn't say glowing
it's implicit glowing review and don't
forget
no po boxes and only in america folks we
can't we don't have the money to ship
you a book in poland we can't ship books
to mongolia people okay so listen if you
want more of life's big questions find
us on social media at reza aslan and at
rayne wilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake
let us know your life's big questions we
would love to explore them on a future
episode and as usual remember to follow
rate and review metaphysical milkshake
on apple podcasts or wherever you listen
to podcasts and
you can subscribe to the metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel and watch our
full episodes every week
thanks for listening
that's like 50 thousand dollars right
there love love
love somebody cut me off before we run
out of money metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rayne wilson reza
aslan and colin thompson it is produced
by safa samasa de jazz harris lane mick
dimaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
so you've learned some things about how
to have more effective zoom and facetime
communications i i'm sure you've already
felt it i mean you i'm probably giving
off so much zoom wise right now you seem
very agreeable to me not disagreeable
not not a disagreement like at least a
six or a seven
out of a hundred
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you